[Música]
México celebró los comicios regionales
para elegir a los gobernadores de los
estados de Coahuila y México el más
poblado del país ambos bastiones del Pri
donde no ha habido alternancia política
la jornada inaugura el calendario
electoral y mide el pulso de los
partidos de Cara a las presidenciales de
2024 vamos a la capital
[Música]
ante la violencia rampante cada vez más
haitianos toman la justicia en sus
propias manos con machetes y piedras
persiguen a los integrantes de las
pandillas que en los primeros meses del
año asesinaron hirieron o secuestraron a
más de 1.600 personas según la ONU
este lunes es el Día Mundial del medio
ambiente y por ello vamos a Brasil
porque la deforestación de la amazonía
continúan niveles vertiginosos el
problema aumento de exponencialmente
bajo el gobierno de Jair bolsonaro y El
Ejecutivo de Lula da Silva Busca
revertir las medidas mientras que ong
denuncian dificultades para defender el
territorio
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
México que este domingo celebró
elecciones regionales para elegir
gobernadores de los estados de México y
Coahuila ambos territorios bastiones del
izquierdista pri Y en donde en más de 90
años no ha habido alternancia política
en estos comicios hubo dos alianzas la
oficialista Juntos hacemos historia y la
opositora va por México en la que
confluyen dos rivales históricos el pri
Y el derechistan conectamos con Mario
carbonel corresponsal de France 24 Mario
Cuál fue el balance general de esta
jornada
Hola qué tal pues se fue una jornada de
amplia participación ciudadana la
autoridad electoral reportó una buena
afluencia en las casillas también se
transcurrió de manera tranquila sin
embargo la fiscalía especializada en
delitos electorales reportó haber
recibido 23 denuncias por ilegalidades
de índole Federal 19 en el Estado de
México y tres en Coahuila pero no algo
de gravedad también la jornada estuvo
marcada por tres características
peculiares En primera instancia son dos
mujeres las que contienen el estado de
México De tal suerte que será una mujer
quien gobierne esa entidad en los
próximos seis años por primera vez en
esa entidad en el Estado de México las
personas privadas de su libertad con
prisión preventiva pudieron ejercer su
derecho al voto estamos hablando de más
de 4.700 internos también por primera
ocasión se utilizó de México la urna
electrónica fueron 164 urnas
electrónicas las que se dispusieron en
20 distritos la organización fue de 100%
de Casillas instaladas únicamente una de
más de
24,400 Casillas no pudo instalarse por
motivos de seguridad pero en general sin
por menores también por primera vez
mexicano residentes en el extranjero
pudieron acudir a los consulados de
Chicago Dallas Los Ángeles y también en
Montreal Canadá a emitir su voto estamos
hablando de 73 mil mexicanos residentes
en el exterior de manera tal que ha sido
una jornada que se ha caracterizado por
eso por la civilidad de la ciudadanía y
por también una participación importante
María usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación nosotros previamente hablamos
con Juan Carlos Cali mayor analista
político y experto en derecho de la
Universidad Autónoma de Guadalajara y
quien nos contó si estos comicios sirven
de pulso para los partidos de Cara a las
presidenciales de 2024
por supuesto primero por el monto de por
el monto de electores que es alto
estamos hablando del doce por ciento
de los electores del país de 13% y
porque prácticamente a partir de mañana
arrancan ya las campañas por la
presidencia por definir candidatos a la
presidencia los anuncios que harán
mañana tanto la coalición gobernante
como la coalición opositora van en ese
sentido y será como el banderazo de
salida para primero definir candidatos
en cada partido definir el método de
elección en cada partido y las
elecciones pues todavía falta serán
hasta junio del próximo año pero
prácticamente en base a lo que sucedió
hoy tenemos que qué estrategias vienen
si hubiera perdido Morena la elección en
el edomex yo creo que había habría gran
entusiasmo por parte de los opositores
al
de que sí se les puede ganar pero esto
para los opositores deja un Claro sin
sabor de que es difícil y desde que
todavía Nadie puede anticipar a
victorias al menos doce personas
perdieron la vida tras el colapso de una
mina de oro en la amazonía venezolana a
las autoridades reportaron que los
mineros fallecieron el miércoles luego
de que el yacimiento se inundara por las
lluvias y el grupo quedará bajo tierra
sin suministro de oxígeno la mina se
encuentra en el callao en el estado de
Bolívar y los expertos forenses
explicaron que trabajan en la
identificación de los cuerpos para
entregar los restos a las familias
en Haití tan solo en los primeros meses
del año 1630 personas fueron asesinadas
heridas o secuestradas según la ONU pero
desde abril esas cifras parecen haber
disminuido por la acción de civiles que
empezaron a defenderse por sí mismos la
hija de él nos cuenta más
frente a la impunidad de las bandas
ciertos haitianos están contraatacando
son ellos ahora los que matan y a veces
queman cuerpos de presuntos pandilleros
en la capital Puerto Príncipe este nuevo
movimiento tiene un nombre
hoy no son los Estados Unidos Francia o
Canadá quienes vendrán a sacarnos de
nuestra situación es con un machete como
podremos salir de esta situación
con machetes piedras y otras armas
improvisadas estos civiles empezaron a
proteger ciertos barrios hartos de la
impotencia de la policía frente a los
pandilleros que controlan mediante el
terror el 80% de Puerto Príncipe que la
Policía Nacional haitiana a pesar de los
esfuerzos que realiza a pesar de la
cantidad de cooperación internacional
que reside en equipamiento en
entrenamiento en distintos insumos en la
práctica no está en la capacidad hoy de
defender a su pueblo en un país sin
presidente desde el asesinato de Ruth en
el Moisés hace dos años otro factor que
explica la creación de guacale es la
incompetencia del gobierno haitiano
según este abogado
Por qué el pueblo ha decidido actuar Así
es porque tras una serie de
observaciones el pueblo considera que el
ministro de justicia y el primer pero
Ariel Angie están al frente del poder
pero no hacen nada
el centro de análisis y de investigación
en derechos humanos haitiano destacó que
desde la formación de guacale el 24 de
abril los secuestros y asesinatos han
disminuido de manera significativa pero
el estallido de esta justicia popular
también preocupaba varios expertos
haitianos podría utilizarse para atacar
a personas inocentes o dar lugar a una
explosión de violencia aún Peor si las
pandillas buscan venganza
este lunes es el Día Mundial del medio
ambiente en Brasil activistas denuncian
amenazas y numerosos problemas
logísticos para defender la amazonía
cuya deforestación aumentó
exponencialmente bajo el gobierno de
Jair bolsonaro Rodrigo sedano nos cuenta
más
un Vergel rico en biodiversidad el
pulmón del mundo que año año ve mermada
su extensión debido a la deforestación
ilegal en 2020 perdió
10.267 kilómetros cuadrados marcando un
récord histórico en el último año de
gobierno de Jair bolsonaros según
observadores nacionales una tendencia
que busca cambiar su sucesor Lula da
Silva con la vuelta de las redadas
antideforestación entre otras medidas el
trabajo de ong es como rioterra también
es clave en la reforestación
la fuerza de la destrucción es mucho más
grande que la de la reconstrucción
tardas años en recuperar un área pero
una persona con una máquina tarda
segundos en tirar todo al suelo
su trabajo se centra en plantar nuevos
árboles en granjas y zonas deforestadas
se enfrentan Sin embargo a los
asesinatos de activistas ambientales
según la organización global witness 342
entre 2021 y 2022 desde la organización
Black Jaguar apuntan también a otros
problemas
necesitamos la confianza de los
campesinos y necesitamos confiar en las
comunidades locales el otro problema
definitivamente es la necesidad que
tenemos de crear nuestras propias
infraestructuras
pese a ello insisten en la tarea de
ayudar a realizar el corredor de
biodiversidad de araguaya
es un proyecto masivo de reforestación
El corredor en sí tiene 2.600 kilómetros
de largo y 40 de ancho con la ayuda de
las comunidades las autoridades
brasileñas y la comunidad internacional
esperan conseguir sus metas para Ben
vals las razones simple no enfrentamos
un cambio climático sino una crisis
climática con impacto global llegamos
así al final de esta emisión de noticias
en France 24 ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía quédense con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]